excuse my language but what the hell is
going on this is uh 20 22. what are we
seeing here what is this yeah the i
somebody sends this video to me and we
were women or daughters of the family
cannot say no wait hold on if the
husband
the husbands were taken to the
conservation camps they'll be taken to
these camps then that's right many
traditional muslim names are even banned
for newborns images of xi jinping have
been placed in some mosques and on
prayer mats across the province an act
that offends religious sensibilities
beards and face veils have been banned
as have some halal products
[Music]
i bet you are all excited for the
olympic games that are right around the
corner now the olympic games are the
world's only truly global multi-sport
celebratory happy day athletics
competition with more than 200 countries
participating in over 400 events across
the summer and winter games
the olympics are where the world comes
to compete feel inspired and be together
in guess where this year beijing china
now make sure that you visit the modern
day inquisition holocaust genocide caps
that china is also hosting while the
world is enjoying sports fun and freedom
a genocide rape of women abduction of
children the list goes on of the evil
things that china is doing to these
innocent women men and children while
the world sleeps eats and enjoys the
olympic games sponsored by china and
friends
to tell us more about this we have our
special guest dr erikan siddique who is
the senior advisor to the world uber
congress and the founder of uger academy
assalamu alaikum
welcome
i'm very glad to be here
it's very nice to have you with us thank
you for
being with us here on the dean show so
are you are you uh everybody's getting
ready for the olympics
uh no it is a very sad event for us
and that's very very tragic to see that
you know the world as i opened up is
getting excited to go ahead and enjoy
the sports the food and the festivals
and we're reminding them why don't they
do you think it's a good idea that they
go visit these modern day inquisitions
holocaust genocide camps while they're
there
well if possible yes but uh only the
thing is
china uh has been preparing for
uh some some fake scenes for foreign
visitors for some time now
so even if if they are allowed to go to
east pakistan they will see some staged
scenes not a real one so uh the
important thing is for for those who try
to visit east turkestan they should be
they should make sure that uh they want
to see the real places and the real
people real witnesses otherwise they
will be faked they will be cheated
now i want to go ahead and get your
reaction we have some senators
congressmen who are also talking about
this senator jeff berkley and i'm
congressman jim mcgovern
we are the co-chairs of the
congressional executive commission on
china
in just a few months winter olympic
games are scheduled to begin in beijing
in the shadow of some of the world's
most egregious human rights abuses
we believe it's a mistake for the ioc to
hold these games in china at a time when
the chinese government continues to
commit genocide strip hong kong's
autonomy squeeze journalists free
thinkers and civil society throughout
mainland china
and bully its critics globally
we asked the ioc to postpone and
relocate these olympic games
we asked the corporate sponsors to use
their leverage to stand up for human
rights
they refused and the world now awaits
olympic games with echoes of the 1936
olympics in berlin another time the
prestige of the olympics was used as a
propaganda weapon by a regime trampling
human dignity
the chinese host will put a put on a
spectacle designed to distract from and
cover up the human suffering that the
government inflicts
the chinese government has stained the
olympics it is essential that we
remember that behind the shiny facade
are human beings
today we announce an effort to focus
attention not on the facade but on real
people who are not able to celebrate the
olympic spirit because they are unjustly
imprisoned by the government hosting the
games
for each of the next 60 days in the
lead-up to the opening ceremonies we'll
be highlighting a political prisoner a
day
we will be sharing the cases of members
of civil society lawyers journalists
hong kongers uyghurs and tibetans locked
up merely for exercising their most
basic freedoms
all of these cases are documented in the
commission's political prisoner database
you can learn about them there and by
following this countdown on the
commission's social media and website
we encourage you the public to join us
let the ioc and its partners know that
they should be using their leverage to
put pressure on the chinese government
to release prisoners of conscience and
lessen the stain they are putting on the
olympic spirit
we all want the olympics to be a
celebration of our athletes and a time
for the world to come together
let's take action now to fight for the
true spirit of the olympics and ensure
the games are not abused as a propaganda
tool for human rights abusers
dr erkin please uh excuse my language
but what the hell is going on this is uh
2022 coming up
and are we seriously having what we
study in history books actually happen
today a modern genocide a
modern day inquisition happening while
the world is just watching is asleep
playing at the olympic games
yes uh both you and the two congressmen
could put the issue very well
the thing is i have been uh telling the
world that the whole whole world right
now is headed to a dark era
why i say that the reason is
what the uber people are having right
now
is worse than the holocaust
i have some contact back home the
information i got is
since 2014
about nine
million ugles have been detained
this number may surprise a lot of people
the reason is chinese government has
been telling the world that the euro
population is about 11 or 12 million
they even saved this last year in
reality
the actual population number is about 20
million before 2017.
there is a speech given by a retired u.s
army colonel uh
the lakers vickerson he says in his
speech in 2018 there's about 20 million
rivers in
so uh
now the chinese chinese government has
detained about 9 million of them
they transferred 2.1 million rivers from
concentration camps to the other part of
china
they were
trans transported dispersed and
disappeared
if someone goes there and look for them
today i don't know how many will be
found
another 1.8 million ugos have been
transferred from concentration camp to
prisons and jails
and the rest has been transferred to
forced labor factories
recently
uber projects foundation for which i am
the president and the founder
we
made a list of the companies that
employing ubers as first labor workers
in eastern
owned by han chinese the list goes the
list has more than 14 000 factories
imagine if each factory employs 100 oils
as slave labor workers the total number
will be more than 1.4 million in reality
all of those companies have much more
than 100 people
as workers so this is the real station
and another piece of information i got
is more than one million users have been
killed or died since 2014 the reason
that the concentration camp is extremely
in a bad condition and the detainees are
given only one or two meals in a day
i got an information from a high ranking
police official in istan when he went
abroad when some when my friend asked
him what is the condition in
concentration camp that police official
told him imagine there's no hell on the
earth the situation in the camp is
at least 100 times
worse than the hell this is what he said
this is a quote
and uh
the sisterhood of who lives in uh
netherlands recently testified in
tribunal she was a teacher in several
construction camps in urumqi
when she was working there the
government brought in a several group of
we were imams
when they first arrived they are very
healthy very charming of laughing like
that but after 2-3 months many of them
couldn't stand by themselves they
couldn't walk by themselves the reason
is the weather is so cold there are
given only one's very thin sheet to
cover cover when they slept at night
they slept on the concrete
floor
this way those people many of them
became they couldn't walk by themselves
they couldn't stand by themselves we are
talking about
a time period of two or three months
if if you count from 2014 it has been
seven eight years
it's become from 2017 it's four five
years since the mass number of ubers
were detained
how they can survive jose can keep
themselves alive in a condition like
that so the western reporters still
saying more than 100 people older people
were detained no more than 100 people
have been killed or died since 2014.
this is the situation so i worry about
the world this is not the same does not
end with our people the whole world is
heading to a dark era the reason i say
that is because the everything is
happening right now
is going to happen in china the window
olympic game is like this the principle
of the international olympic game
if you look at the list of their mission
statement
china is not is not implementing any of
them they are doing everything against
it what's the mitchell statement
you're talking about the mission
statement what of the olympic games
that's right please share with us some
of their mission statements
there i don't i didn't prepare for that
right now so i cannot tell you right
away but i was in a meeting in 2019 at
the human rights watch they had a
discussion about that they looked at the
mission statement of the international
communi international community
committee and it is uh what uh what is
happening in china is everything is
access to every item listed there so
something in the world
right now in there it talks about like
freedom it talks about you know humanity
coming together you know these things
that obviously
it's just hypocritical i mean you got to
be consistent like it just doesn't make
sense but not only this olympic game
everything that china is doing if you
look at it
they are little war in a dark era
they are they sign it every piece of
international agreement treaties
something like that but they are
violating every of them and in the whole
world the civilization of the whole
world is is becoming worse and worse on
a daily basis the bigger problem is part
of it and i am so worried about the
future of the of the world
is this uh just bluntly speaking is just
and simplistically is just because like
wherever you go and you pick up an item
it says made in china so does this have
to do with you know pretty much that
people don't want to rock the boat
because everything's made in china
that's right it is part of the chinese
strategy to rule the world
people need to remember if china becomes
the number one in the world the world
will be very different it is
unrecognizable if compared to today's
world this is the situation we are
heading right now the winter olympic
game is part of it people should wake up
people
should stand up against uh mr tyranny i
understand that this whole of the the
destroy destroying of the civilization
by the chinese government this is a very
bad situation there's this video also
that you posted can you tell us give us
a breakdown of this
[Music]
hold on
what are we seeing here what is this
yeah
somebody sends this video to me in this
concentration camp and there are the
guards uh taking some people out from
the from the group and hitting them
until they they couldn't stand anymore
uh i got many pieces of information
about what's happening inside the
constitution camp i just mentioned one
of you
one of them to you so this is inside
this is inside those inquisition camps
this is right that's right this looks
like a school the chinese government
converted many other regular facilities
like schools and hospitals into
conservation camps this one looks like
one of them
and what they do
they torture the detainees
and
ask them to say
thank you sir hitting me
thank you sir beating me
and this is the process of destroying
the human dignity
completely and uh
[Music]
survivors have uh told the world what
they have gone through this one is
actually a better one among the
torturers that they got already so
you're saying this is a way of just
destroying them breaking them down their
human dignity everything right yeah
that's right because
you see i i lost three people that i
know in concentration camp one is my
middle school literature teacher
he was a teacher for a long time i took
many classes from him from 1971 to 76
and he became the principal of the
middle school afterwards but he was
detained in 2018 at the age of 78
and died in the camp two months later
his name is ahadaman
i had another friend young friend who
came to the u.s to study
he got two master degrees from 2000 from
the year of 2000 into 2005 in business
administration
and after that he went back
he was detained in 2018
and stayed in a concentration camp for
about nine months
after he was released he he rushed to
hospital
on the diet nine days later
the reason is internal bleeding his name
is
muthalep nurmamet a very strong very
tall guy
and he was tortured in the concentration
camp
until he
he cannot make it anymore so that's why
they released him but he died nine days
later in orange hospital
you say
i heard many stories like this the
people who were released
if they could survive for for the first
two months they could live otherwise
most of them died within the two months
after releasing from the concentration
camp because all the people got uh
tortured in the in the in the prison
this is one of the
asian chinese tactics to rule the people
it it they they destroy the people both
spiritually and
physically this is happening to the
other people so that when they come out
from the conservation camp they will be
like a ultimatum not a regular person
anymore they only can act after
receiving orders but not by their own
but the reality is
so far the chinese government detained
about 9 million euros but there's not
any release of the people in a
substantial way you only hear here and
there several of them several ten of
them but the rest are gone disappeared
as i said earlier they disappeared to
the chinese provinces to other parts of
china for organ harvesting bio-weapon
experiments
you if you google allah organ harvesting
you will get very interested in
information
the ogre people don't eat pork
so very pure is that in that respect and
the chinese military
marketing them as a halal organ
providers
are the same their organs this is a big
operation people should look it up right
under the chinese government also are
taking some people that they do they
must murder
i call this distributed mass murder
because the chinese government
are doing it in a very secret way like
uh they killed they are killing at night
or they are making the conditions of the
jails prisons concentration camps so bad
that these people cannot survive
i don't know the people who are looked
up currently in prisons uh jails
construction camps if they can survive
for another five to ten years because
the condition is so bad and people are
dying by large numbers if the if the
reporters or investigators total viewers
who are living abroad they will find
every family has several members
that look that are lost already
this is the situation but the world so
far did not do any investigation in this
and get them information from here and
there and saying more than one billion
euros
were detained in reality like in kashgar
prefecture and hotend prefecture about
70 percent of the population were gone
originally before 2016 ninety-five
percent of the populations there were
worse but they're gone like a seventy
percent of them if somebody goes there
today and uh visits those places they
can hardly find over people this is the
reality and that's why i am saying the
situation of your people is much worse
than the holocaust what the world is not
investigating is not sending people to
the ground and take a look chinese
government closed the door they don't
allow any foreigners to go there like
reporters investigators observers and
this chinese government even kicked out
muslim students like pakistani students
from east turkestan
2016. you know why because very bad
thing is happening there
this is the this is the situation
currently this is our situation and we
are very desperate this should be
stopped
what is happening we hear stories is
this confirmed is there evidence that
you have people from this uh
communist party they put them in let's
say an average and i want people to
imagine you're married you got your
family so then is this true that now
they're putting people to stay in the
houses and then having forced marriages
and you have rape and all these other
things is this true can you tell us
what's happening to the women and
children there
yes i got i got a piece of information
just yesterday
from someone who was
studying in other parts of china we were
student and he told information in the
message that
the only the survival path for your
people right now is to get married with
chinese otherwise no way
this is happening
what you mentioned earlier is that uh
installing chinese men into we were
families whose husband has been taken
the number is very large like 1.5
million uber families
so
1.5
million
families have had people placed in their
homes right that's right so you have
google if you google it you can find a
formal report on that yes that
wow this is crazy subhanallah you can't
just imagine i want the american i want
the italian i want just the human being
to imagine you're in your home and
someone places some strange man some
strange person some from some political
party in your home and what's he there
to do
the the rule is to several one is to
just observe them
just watch them so that they don't play
as they don't pray
or they don't do anything religious
another one is to change the mind of
older people to come closer to han
chinese actually uh we heard the story
of the the daughter and the wife getting
raped for example
right now
uber people cannot say no to han chinese
whatever they do this is the this is the
order from the top so chinese men who
are installed to your families can do
anything they want
the we were women or daughters of the
family cannot say no wait hold on
if the husband who has this
if he now he's in his home and now what
can he do so that from the top it's
saying that this man can come and he can
go ahead and have relations with the
man's wife that's right that's right so
what happens is naturally no what
happens if the man doesn't let that
happen his her husband
that the men would were taken the
husbands were taken to the concentration
camps they'll be taken to these camps
then that's right
all those 1.5 million families their
husbands were taken
there's another video here because this
comes down to like what you're saying is
so they're trying to have them detest
their belief and conviction in their
creator the god almighty allah so
they're what they're trying to do is
they're trying to make sure you don't
pray fast
read the verbatim word of god almighty
the quran i mean so is this
i mean this is unheard of at this time
tell us what is this here that's the
that's the big one
yeah this one
this one some chinese restaurant
a build a uh build a restaurant
and put this uh
on the floor so that the guests can step
on it when they want to eat in the
restaurant so this is the kalima this is
the shahada now this is this is from
quran so they're they've actually made
this they've ingrained this on the floor
so people can actually walk on the on
the quran they can walk on the these
ayahs this uh
the kalima they can
this is actually for real
it is real it just this video just came
up
two days ago
actually i can tell you a situation much
worse than this the gazetta
who testified if she's a kazakh lady she
testified during the uber tribunal as
you can find her testimony on my twitter
account or on the internet this is what
she said
in the cell she was staying the guard
handed in a quran
put them in a bucket that the people in
the cell uses as toilet
remember listen carefully
the guard gave quran
to the concentration camp cells
to put it
in a bucket used as toilet
because in the concentration camp sales
there's no toilet
there's a bucket everybody pees and poo
poo is on on it so they put the quran in
the pocket and let them pee and poop on
it
you can find this video
from the world tribunal collections
this is what the godzilla testified
i put this up on the on the twitter and
the the muslims in the world should
think who they are dealing with
because most of the muslim countries in
the world
are on the bed with the chinese
government
they are supporting the chinese
government agnostical people but in
reality
this is the this is the situation what
they are doing
the the thing is the chinese government
assaults is so hype hippie cricket if
you go to china on a business trip the
most muslim countries leaders
the government puts quran
and the janamas in their hotel room
and as those muslim leaders got so
impressing
china is the only country treated us
this way but on the other hand
look at what they are doing to the river
people and what they are doing to the
quran to the ayat
as we saw today subhanallah what could
uh starting with let's say bosnia this
is where my family's from we see a lot
of chinese tourists you go there and you
go to the center of sarajevo and you see
so many chinese tourists there they're
taking pictures having a great time
right so what can some country like
let's say bosnia start with that what
would you advise you know the people and
the politicians you know the leaders the
movers and shakers in a place like
bosnia who have really good rations now
and the tourism is open and chinese come
and enjoy there what would you advise
let's say the bosnian officials there
and then from there you know developing
a framework for the rest of the people
to create this
awareness
yeah on this all this issue i cannot
tell them to do something about the
chinese forests something like that
because they're all brainwashed
in the in on under thinking uh in the
thinking of the whole chinese population
right now that ubers are bad apples
and they should be given the current
type of treatment so even if you talk to
the stores uh you will you will find two
situations one is one of them they don't
know that we were genocide at all and as
one they said it's good the government
did a good thing so i don't know if i
can uh
what kind of advice i can give the
problem is that china's government that
the ccp government that's the huge
problem not only for the river people
but also for the whole world so like
foreign governments should do something
about that
what about masajid we hear mosques you
know are being desecrated they're being
destroyed is this also true
of course the if right now the only one
standing the mosques standing in
circumstances are for two to like a two
deceived foreign visitors
or some of them converted to
entertainment centers
the mosques converted to entertainment
centers where the chinese person go eat
and drink alcohol
you can find many videos like that right
now the rest is gone
most of them are gone the ones that
still standing are for other purposes
political purposes
this is just hard to imagine in fathom
that
we're going on 20 22
and now someone who wants to practice
their god-given right their freedom to
go ahead and read
their book that they believe from the
creator the quran if they want to greet
the same way jesus greeted peace be with
you you know if they say uh god is the
greatest allahu akbar you know they can
actually be taken down to these camps
and of course
yeah not that kind of work even like uh
i sometimes greet people i always great
people like assalam or aslama alaikum
you cannot use this word
in in in turkish time you cannot use
this no
even the names name is muhammad
abdullah i had all this kind of names
are
forbidden wait hold on now even we've
heard this but now i mean i mean i it's
just hard to imagine so now if you want
to name your son let's say you want to
name your son isa right or musa moses
after moses you you can't you can't do
this no it's not allowed
you're kidding me no it's not allowed if
you do that you will go to concentration
camp that's it okay so how did they go
ahead and justify this how are they
getting away with this you know okay we
hear the excuse it's an educational camp
because these are extremists these are
radicals is that that is that the
pretext that is being used
they're still using that they're still
using that but in reality you say that
what they
what what they captured so far that
detained the number is very huge says
basically the chinese government is
against the uber
race itself not a religious belief or
something like that but of course they
they consider the religion as a poison
and
we have many witnesses who went to jails
in the past and the police tortured them
making them naked and torture them after
that they burn the ladies we were lady
with cigarettes and say call your gut to
rescue you
there is one lady like this in
netherlands you can talk to her she has
gone through this in her body you can
find about 100 uh burn marks and the the
guard uh did this kind of things to her
just burned her face with cigarettes say
call your god to save you that's what
you say subhanallah did they
in uk they had an independent tribunal
that also concluded that this was now uh
the genocide is definitely taking place
they interviewed witnesses and they came
to this
uh verdict
that's right that's uh this is that's
why um
we will give a legal basis to the
genocide being committed by the chinese
government the sad truth is even after
that just like yesterday
the i o see
uh some other obviously uh the officials
said they don't know there's a
construction camps hold on hold on this
is it
so hold on they had the tribe you know
it's like a court in uk you know they
did this and they brought the witnesses
experts right you know this is not some
like uh bamboo court they
they interviewed the witnesses they
concluded that this is actually a
genocide happening so now what's the the
uh
people are still these ioc and what are
these heads of the olympic games and
others they're what are they saying
they're saying
they don't know there's concentration
camps are you kidding me right this is
like a this is like i mean it's kind of
it's hard to just wrap your mind around
this it's like
that's why that's why i'm saying this
this whole the whole world is is heading
to a dark era
because the people lost decency
just like these people lost decency i
mean
look at we have proofs
evidence is everywhere and they still
say they don't believe or they don't
know there's construction camps
so that's the the saying you know when
when good people you know remain silent
rather be a jew a christian you know uh
whoever is out there you have uh where
are the feminists you know where where
are where are the the women's rights
movements where is everybody to be
making noise right when something
happens out there pray for this pray for
that but now you have how many millions
of people modern day inquisition in
these concentration camps a genocide is
happening and the world is getting ready
to enjoy
the olympic games in the actual place
where it's happening in china that's
right so people called it a genocide
game that's a very good name for it
and uh
i i i know this is going to leave a um
stain
on everybody who supported this kind of
act right now
and i don't know how the the olympic
game um
the the people who are participating in
the game
or uh
or the fighting in the game
or competing in the games how they deal
with this
it's a very sad situation it's a it's a
it will be the stain of the century as
pompeo pointed out
uh it's very association yeah because
now what side of history are you upon
are you on the right side the wrong side
so anybody who's participating would you
say in the olympic games from the
athletes to the countries i mean this is
a call for them to boycott i mean this
is this is where you can actually you
know make a difference no that's right
the one one sad truth is
when the when the international
community boycotted the olympic game in
moscow
i don't know which year it is 1936 or 19
some
something
the 44 countries
joined it to the boycotting
activity but this time
uh on december 9th
uh president biden invited 110 countries
to the summit of democracy
among them
only six countries so far
signed up to work at the beijing
olympics look at this comparison what
happened
what happened in the last half a century
time
where the world is heading right now
it's very saturation
it's very sad for us
also it's very sad to the whole world
thank you uh we're out of time is there
anything else that you'd like to share
with us how can people get more informed
how can people follow some of your work
have you yourself um have you i mean has
your life have been threatened have you
do you fear for things happening to you
because uh we we hear all sorts of you
know people getting shut down because
they're speaking the truth
that's true the i live in the us
and i also work for nasa i am a senior
optical engineer so i have some
guarantee about my safety
but the thing is uh
in 2006 2007 and 2009 i visited my
homeland
and i met with many students more than
thousand students
and they all disappeared
uh this truth is is the cause that keeps
me
awake at night
i have been thinking to do something
about that
it's a very situation i lost so many
people
um
i hope the world realize what they are
into right now and this is not just a
real problem uh it may not have
something to do with you as many of the
people living right now but
the development is very scary
what the chinese ccp regime
is trying to do is very scary
it may change the fate of this whole
world so i hope people don't keep silent
uh stand for justice and the humanity uh
including the river people they i am
very worried the older people my current
estimate is people in the
prisons
jails construction camps may live for
another five to ten years
people who are working in factories as
the first labor work workers may live
for another 20 30 years
and the other people other people in
tarkistan can only live maybe 60 or 70
years
after that this is turkestan the uru
land becomes a no over land
the one race will be wiped out from the
surface of this earth people should be
concerned about this
and we appreciate we are very grateful
for all those who are supporting our
cause
trying to save the river people thank
you
yeah if anybody out there has any ounce
of good iota for human life
you know do your part go ahead and share
this get the information out so you can
help make a small part of a big huge
difference that can happen especially at
these olympic games hopefully many
politicians more people movers and
shakers can step up and really even the
players start to boycott this 2020 uh
two olympics that's happening
where the genocide is happening in
beijing china you can go ahead and make
a difference by taking yes
yeah another another appeal i have is i
am the co-founder of the president of
uber projects foundation it is a
non-profit organization
uh registered in the us our goal is to
preserve the world language culture
identity abroad
uh the uber population is very small
outside china um they have only about
one hundred thousand we were people
outside the east
and outside of central asia so we are
trying to preserve the language culture
and the uber identity among this 100
people 100 000 people in diaspora so
please help us if you can financially we
are doing many projects
in this regard and i'll be very grateful
for your help
thank you very much may god almighty the
creator of allah bless you for taking
this stance and educating the people on
what's going on this modern day
genocide holocaust inquisitions that's
happening it's just very like you said
the world's head in a dark place good
people need to step up doesn't matter
what religion you're from if you've got
any ounce of humanity in you you need to
take a stand otherwise it can happen to
you tomorrow god bless you very much
thank you thank you doctor thank you so
much for giving us this opportunity
thank you assalamu alaikum welcome
peace